It's great to welcome to the program. Sean
McFate who is senior fellow at the Atlantic
council and also [inaudible]
there are most recently of the new rules of
war victory in the age of durable disaster.
Sean, it's so great to have you back.
Great to be back with you Dave.
So we've been following a lot of different
geopolitical and also sort of military related
stories. We had what looked like it was heading
in the direction of a big escalation with
Iran. That did not happen. We've been talking
about the possible different paths that the
future of the three big super powers the U
S China and Russia could could potentially
take. And in that context, talking about technology
militaries, China's declining birth rate and
all of these different factors that could
play a role if you just were to big picture
for us, the changes that we've seen to the
dynamics of the superpowers over the last
couple of years under Donald Trump. How, how,
what has changed I guess is maybe where to
start.
Well, the first thing is that Donald Trump
has really doubling down on the defense budget.
Uh, the U S [inaudible] budget is bigger than
the next seven biggest militaries in the world
combined. It's sort of like the Ronald Reagan
buildup. And I think in some ways, and there's
a shift away from terrorism to great power
competition like Russia and China, Iran. And
in some ways that's smart, but what's not
smart is what we're investing in and how we
think we're going to fight those Wars if it
becomes a war.
Can you give some examples of that in the
sense that, I mean, I think we, we've talked
about how whenever there is a discussion of
a possible war, now our minds probably still
go to the type of warfare of times past. And
that's not realistically what it would look
like. But what would it look like? What would
the sort of battle lines be?
So in the, the old rules of war, the way you
won war is battlefield victory. Take a Waterloo,
Gettysburg, Stalin grad, and midway. But when
was the last time battlefield victory swayed
a war in the last 70 years? No, none, no times.
So warfare has changed. We think in terms
of conventional war. We think that the future
war is gonna be like world war II with our
technology. But in fact we're, we're, we're,
we're has gone to his strategic deception
and what matters now is worst became epistemological.
So what matters now is not like battlefield
victory. It matters what people and populations
think. So what, what does victory look like
now? Well, let me ask you a question. I mean,
like right now we're engaged in a cultural
war and guys, it's America, right? If Fox
versus CNN, Democrats was Republican, all
those things, now we know that democracies
are messy. And that's okay. If we're having
an organic family dispute, what's not okay
is a foreign powers are funding the fissures
in our society and flannel fanning those flames
deliberately. And that's indeed what's going
on. It's a form of warfare. It's, and it's
not something that F 30 fives can fight.
Is it? Uh, so, so I understand what you're
saying. I still though, so let me give you
a counter example and see where you think
it fits in. In the discussion of a possible
escalation with Iran. We saw some pretty good
pieces that said from a strategy and tactics
perspective, Iran will be very different than
Iraq. Iran is, military is much stronger than
Iraq. The land, uh, the, the sort of geographical
realities of Iran are very different than
Iraq, mountainous and very different. Those
seem like analyses more related to the sort
of traditional battlefield and they seem relevant.
Are they, are they partially relevant? Are
they relevant in a different way or is that
not even a reasonable analysis to be making?
It's not a reasonable analysis at all, really.
I mean, no, I mean to invade Iran would be
like to invade China or to invade Moscow.
You know, both the Napoleon and the Nazis
learned not to invade Russia. Um, you know,
just because you have more troops and more
bullets does not mean you're going to win
Wars. Uh, so what's going on in look around
what's going on in a rain right now? Well,
we know we killed, I mean we know that Iran
and Russia in the last 10 years have really
come to dominate middle East politics. We
kind of lost and Russia is filling the void
and so is Iran. And the way they're fighting
is not like the Iraq, Iran war of days of
old. They're using secret type of weapons
using [inaudible]. They will using a cud,
special forces, Hezbollah, terrorist proxy
groups, propaganda, all these things. And
you know what?
So does Russia, they use spats not to use
mercenaries. Like the Wagner group, they use
little green men. They use these, these fake
proxy militias. They use propaganda and active
measures. That's how they took the Crimea,
right? And this is also how I ran, is taken
the Lavant haven't taken Syria and they're
doing it not through troops on the ground
and tanks and mountainous. They're doing it
through deception. And the reason is is that
we live in an information age or weapons that
give you a plausible deniability like terrorists
and special forces on propaganda. Weapons
that give you plausible deniability or more
potent than firepower. We in the U S are still
focusing on firepower, but warfare has completely
changed. Iran and Russia fight this way. We
do not.
Hmm. So let's, let's keep talking about fire
power a little bit then nuclear weapons. Um,
a lot of the conversation around Iran stemmed
from the 2015 Iran nuclear deal, which as
far as we knew at the time that Donald Trump
decided to bail on it. Iran was abiding by,
of course, since then, Iran has now said,
well, if, if the U S is out, we're not going
to abide by it anymore. Can you talk a little
bit about in the new sort of framework of
what war would look like, what role do nuclear
weapons have? Because often the conversation
is merely about if the U S gets to have them,
who are we to say Iran doesn't the legitimacy
of the UN security council. That's often the
conversation I got a call or a couple of weeks
ago who said, you know, David, what's not
being discussed is it's possible that Iran
getting nuclear weapons could be a moderating
influence in the sense that sometimes once
countries have nuclear weapons, they see themselves
as part of a sort of different tier or echelon
and it can actually tone down radical rhetoric.
What, what do you think about that? Where
do you come down on the role of nuclear weapons
in new warfare?
That's a great question. First of all, um,
the JC JC Koa is on hospice care. It's, it's,
it's done. And, uh, we also know that Russia
has working behind the scenes, the UN to let
the arms embargo on Iran expire so that come
October we can see, you know, Iran and Russia
really doubling down on conventional weapons
in terms of nuclear weapons WMD. Um, it's
probably inevitable that we, that I ran at
some point we'll get a nuclear weapon, we
can bomb Natanz with a nuclear would take
a nuclear weapon, maybe a J dam. They hit
it, um, that will slow it down. Uh, we can
also try to assassinate their scientists as
Israel has done that can slow it down. But
I think we have to be prepared to live in
a world that may have a nuclear Iran. And
if they do, we have to ask ourselves, are
they really going to deploy it?
I mean, everybody assumes they're going to
deploy it. And I don't know if that's true.
People said this about North Korea before
North Korea became nuclear. And in fact, once
I ran is a nuclear power. We still have levers
of, of power, levers, a diplomacy we can pull
on them. It's not Armageddon despite their
fierce rhetoric. I'm not being an apologist
for Iran, but there are people who treat it
like us. The moment they get a nuclear weapon
as a moment, you know, Tel Aviv and New York
city go up in a mushroom cloud. And I think
some of that is just fear-mongering.
Well, there's no question that, uh, the use
of a nuclear weapon would be, would be self-destructive.
There's no question about that. But I guess
the broader question is, when it comes to
policy, would the presence of or, or the more
serious potential to have a nuclear weapon
make that country perceived as more important
to negotiate with? I mean, there are examples
from history. We can look at Iran, we can
look at, uh, you know, within, within the
Soviet union instances where there has been
a disarming where we're, uh, there've been
agreements to disarm that the future has not
gone particularly well for some of those countries.
So if you look at history, it's understandable
why countries would see nuclear weapons or
at least the serious potential of them as
a good negotiating tool or something that's
good to have.
That's right. I mean, look at North Korea.
They were, they were treated as a B list player
at best before they got nuclear weapons. Now
people pay attention to them when they, when
they speak, and they're not going to give
up a nuclear weapons despite whatever the
Trump administration promises. Look at Ukraine,
they gave up their nuclear weapons after the
Soviet union collapsed. United States promised
them, Oh, we'll protect you. Have Russia ever
gets aggressive. And then when Russia got
aggressive in 2014, the U S broke its promise.
So I think the entire world knows that it's
better to have nuclear weapons than not. And
it shouldn't just go to the victors of the,
of you know, world war II. Um, I think the
danger is a, say a nuclear world war one,
Syria of a moment, if I ran, ever gets a nuclear
weapon. We know Israel has nuclear weapons
and many believe that Saudi Arabia has a secret
deal with Pakistan.
Saudi Arabia used to have a nuclear program,
the 70s, 80s, and the U S uh, they, you know,
talk them out of it, but some believe that
they, that Saudi has made a secret deal of
Pakistan giving them all their research and
all their money and said, you develop nuclear
weapons. And if we ever need one, we'll just
secretly buy a dozen from you. And so very
quickly we could have a nuclear Iran, uh,
you know, Saudi Arabia is real and there's
a threat of accidental war, like in 1914,
Syria of a moment, but it doesn't last for
four years at last, you know, 30 minutes.
And that would be tragic.
What do you see as the role of, uh, organizations
like the United nations? We've talked about
NATO a lot since Donald Trump has been president
and shared defense treaties. There's this
streak of both. I mean, it starts with nationalism,
but it often leads to a sort of isolationism
in some cases. What, what do you see as the
role of, of, uh, multinational organizations,
joint defense treaties, et cetera, in the
next 10 to 15 years?
It's a great question. I mean, first of all,
the question about NATO is long overdue. And
Donald Trump's not the first person to ask
what's their mission? Right. Um, that's, that's
hardly new. Or do you think the international
organizations, the United nations have passed
the expiration date? They have failed to evolve
with the world. Right now we're in a world
where, you know, it's not the world that we
imagine the world diplomats imagine is state
centric. You know, States are everything and
everything that's not state is called sub
state politics. But we live in a world where
the fortune 500 are more powerful than most
States or the super, super duper rich. The
0.1% globally are more powerful than then
the most States and where mercenaries are
back. So anybody who's rich enough can can
go to war for any reason they want. I mean
it's anybody can swipe a paycheck, can become
a superpower.
Eventually ExxonMobil gets its own army bill
Gates, it gets his own army, mega churches,
all the guards, they all get their own militaries.
So the UN is still stuck in the state centric
worldview and they're not, they're not likely
to leave that. And so is international law,
which is why they become less and less relevant
for mitigating and managing conflicts around
the world. Whether that's Rwanda or the Congo
or Iraq or Afghanistan at most are just a
rubber stamp. They're just either they're
stationary at in most. And I think either
ha they either have to evolve or they're just
going to become lip service.
Well, but the evolution of a, of an organization
like NATO look like
of NATO, I think that NATO is, uh, I think
NATO path past expiration date because after,
uh, after the cold war it stopped becoming
a military Alliance, became a pro democracy
Alliance and now it's, it's kind of run half
by diplomat diplomatic thing can happen on
military think, um, if there's going to be
a real Alliance and collective security lies,
look at what Poland is doing on the East.
So Eastern Europe they take Russia's threatened
very seriously and they're kind of forming
a, uh, an informal security cooperation pact.
And I think something like that might be more
of a model, but it needs to be, NATO would
have to be once again seized with defense
as its primary mission and not being used
as a tool for, you know, human rights and
democracy. As important as those things are,
that's not the original nature of a defense
Alliance.
We've been speaking with Sean McFate, who
is a senior fellow at the Atlantic council,
also author most recently of the book, new
rules of war victory in the age of durable
disaster. Sean, so great having you on today.
Thank you. David's speaking back in your show